the wrong things in our world of
glamorous fast cars tomato throwing
contests actors instead of the right
things going to bed early long walks
observing the sky at dusk kindness it's
not that nothing at all is glamorous
it's just that we need to direct our
admiration and excitement more wisely we
need to turn it upon the things which
genuinely deserve prestige artists can
help us one of the fundamental things
that art can do for us is turn the
spotlight of glamour in the best and
most helpful directions artists identify
things that we tend to overlook but
which ideally we should care about
deeply serving women bread and milk were
not especially exciting in the late
1650s when Johann Vermeer painted this
picture she wasn't a celebrity he isn't
showing us somebody who was already
highly admired yet Vermeer saw in this
serving woman pouring milk something
that he felt deserved prolonged
contemplation and admiration he thought
something really important was going on
by worldly standards it's a pretty
humble situation but the care with which
she works is moving Vermeer is impressed
by the idea that our true needs might be
really rather simple bread and milk
already rather satisfying the light
coming through the window is beautiful
and a plain white wall can be a major
source of delight Vermeer is
redistributing glamour by raising the
prestige of things he depicts and he's
trying to get us to feel the same way
the milkmaid is a kind of propaganda or
advert for homely pleasures or consider
the painstakingly skilful and commercial
business of lace making Vermeer paint
the self-employed businesswoman with the
usual diversion and care that would be
given to a military hero or a great
political leader Vermeer was himself
unremarkable in many ways he was born in
1632 in the small but beautiful city of
Delft where his father was a modestly
successful art dealer come in peeper he
stayed there most of his life he never
travelled away from Delft after his
marriage at age 20 he hardly even left
his Pleasant home he and his wife
Katharina had 11 surviving children and
he did much of his painting from a room
on the upper floor Vermeer was a slow
painter partially because he was not
only a painter he continued the family
businesses of art dealing and in keeping
and he also became head of the local
Guild of painters in contemporary terms
his career was not a huge success
he wasn't especially famous and he
didn't make a lot of money he was in
fact an exemplary member of what was in
those days a nearly important kind of
person the middle-class individual
Vermeer was in his teens when Holland or
technically the seven provinces became
an independent state
the first burgeois republic in contrast
to the semi-feudal aristocratic nations
that surrounded it Holland gave honour
and political power to people who are
not at the pinnacle of society to
merchants administrators prosperous
artisans and entrepreneurs it was the
first country in the world to be
recognizably modern in this era and a
great insight of Christianity one which
is easily detachable from the
surrounding theology became increasingly
relevant that everybody's inner life is
important even if on the outside they
don't seem to be particularly
distinguished
Vermeer paints the girl with a Pearl
Earring with the same kind of
consideration she isn't anybody famous
or important she isn't rich the earrings
she wears is nice but it's a minor
trinket in the eyes of the fashionable
world it's the one pricey thing she
earns
yet she's not in need of justice she's
not downtrodden or badly treated she is
for want of a better term ordinary yet
she is like everyone not in the least
bit ordinary she is uniquely
profoundly and mysteriously herself the
picture which best thumbs up for me is
philosophy the little street has become
one of the most famous works of art in
the world
it is brightly placed in Amsterdam's
great Rijksmuseum it is insured for
perhaps half a billion euros and it's
the subject of a mountain of Leonard
articles yet the painting is pointedly
out of sync with its status because
above all else it wants to show us that
the ordinary can be very special the
picture says that looking after a simple
but beautiful home cleaning the yard
watching the children diamond cloth and
doing these things faithfully and
without despair is life's real duty it
is an anti-heroic picture a weapon
against the false images of glamour it
refuses to accept that true glamour
depends on amazing feats of courage or
the attainment of status it argues that
doing the modest things the things that
are expected of all of us is enough
Vermeer did not live long
he died in 1675 when he was still only
in his early 40s but he had communicated
a crucial and hugely sane idea much of
what matters to us is not the exciting
urgent or dramatic or special things
most of life has taken up with dealing
with things at a routine modest humble
and to be honest a touch dull our
culture should focus on getting us to
appreciate the average the ordinary and
the everyday when Vermeer painted his
hometown he didn't choose a special day
the sky was neither very overcast nor
especially sunny nothing is happening
there are no celebrities around yet it
is as he has taught us to recognize all
very special indeed
you